first up in the category of worst we
have Oscar Isaac's Prosthetics from
X-Men this look was just so big and
bulky it overshadowed the entire
performance even Oscar admitted
apocalypse that was excruciating and it
was mostly because of the costume
apparently Oscar hadn't realized that he
was going to be encased in glue latex
and a 40 pound suit for the role when he
signed on plus he had to sit on a
specially designed saddle and be rolled
into cooling tents between takes and so
I just wouldn't ever talk to anybody and
I was just going to be sitting and I
couldn't really move not only could he
barely move but he could barely speak
either the squeaking of the rubber and
plastic on his suit meant that
everything needed to be redubbed later
you can really see Oscar's discomfort
with his costume